[Music]  the EU financial priorities beyond 2020  should adapt to new challenges MEP say  Parliament is in favor of more funds for  jobs growth promotion and investment  members are discussing ways to end  animal testing in the cosmetics industry  around the world MEP is are looking into  the EU s capacity to handle a potential  electricity crisis they also want to  improve customers rights including the  freedom to choose an electricity  supplier and clearer bills what are the  current and future challenges facing  Schengen MEP s we'll look at the areas  in largeman as well as controls at  internal and external borders mayor's  from across the EU will be in Parliament  Thursday to share best practices on  reducing emissions and increasing local  energy production to help meet the --use  climate goals